دانا الولايات المتحده ما وصفته بالهجمات
المروعه على مخيمات النازحين السوريين في
ادلب شمال غربيه سوريا من قبل نظام الاسد
وداعمه الروس وطالبت بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن
ذلك وقال حساب سفاره الامريكيه في دمشق
على تويتر انه كما هي الحاله في اوكرانيا
فاين روسيا تستخدم المعلومات المضلله في
سوريا للقاء اللون على الضحايا وصرف
الانتباه عما سمته اجرام روسيا وحلفائها
وكان عشره مدنيين قتلوا بينهم نساء واطفال
وجرح اكثر من 70 جراء استهداف في قوات
النظام السوري بالصواريخ اوراجون محمله
بقنا بالعقديه مخيمات هي نازحين سوريين في
ادلب وفق الدفاع المدني السوري
هذا وقد نظم اهالي مخيمات النازحين في ريف
ادلب الغربي وقفه احتجاجيه للتمديد بما
وصفوه بالمجزره التي نفذتها قوات النظام
السوري من خلال قصفها مخيمات النازحين
وطالب المشاركون المجتمع الدوليه بحمايه
المدنيين ومحاسبه مرتكبي هذه الجرائم
[موسيقى]